I had not known Richard Ernst before
nineteen sixty-nine when I moved from
Bell Labs to say ETH in Zurich and
Richard had just moved from California
to the ETH a few months before I did and
they didn't have offices for us so they
just put wooden barracks on top of the
physical chemistry building and the two
of us were there side by side isolated
from everybody else and we had
instrumentation joint the common
instrumentation in the basement and
that's how we started to interact and
then we organized a big Congress
together that was in 1974 and during the
time we prepared this Congress
essentially all the P developments
happened sail out the pool published his
first paper on Cygnet ography 1973
Janelle had talked about two-dimensional
NMR at summer school in 1971 and then
Ernst realized two-dimensional NMR
experiment because Jeanette didn't
publish and he didn't follow up adjust
this sisters gave out the idea that's
why he wasn't included in the Nobel
Prize there is no documentation of his
contribution and so when we when we
organized this meeting it is the IC MLPs
international conference or magnetic
resonance in biological systems together
in 1974 it was a turning point of NMR in
biology and in medicine they and they re
verged close together and from their own
we actually worked together for more
than 10 years so we had joint research
programs we had joint employees and I
think it's fair to say that between the
two of us return multi-dimensional NMR
into a useful method not only for
biological work but for chemistry at
large and this meant long hours we often
discussed until midnight well he had
only two and you see this was a very
small group and we were very tight not
to lead led the information out before
it was ready and so we would describe
this it was very difficult see there
were experimental details to be soft and
we needed a company to make new hardware
so that our ideas could actually be put
into experiments notice it was a very
intense collaboration